hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to it's
practically a cliche to make fun of the
Star Wars prequels we all know they're
not very good and we all know they suck
the big one when compared to the
original trilogy it feels like there's
nothing left to talk about well in my
opinion there is one other thing to talk
about the good stuff hear me out just
because a movie or movie series is bad
doesn't mean there can't be some good
things about it when a series has this
much money and dare I say it even effort
thrown into it it's good to acknowledge
when that money and effort actually pays
off are there more good moments than bad
hell no but it's only fair when a movie
series even one as bad as this does a
few things right they're not to be
ignored and deserve being paid attention
to and we're gonna look at the top 11 of
them here today why top 11 because I
like to go one step beyond so sit back
and enjoy the top 11 actual good moments
from the Star Wars prequel
number 11 that kick-ass sword fight the
fighting in these movies definitely got
a lot better when the prequels got
started even the most intense moments in
the original trilogy mostly kept it just
two people tapping swords but the
storyline characters still kept us
interested well since there was shit
storyline and characters in the first
film dailies made up for it with a
pretty cool sword fight instead of two
people it's three and instead of just
tapping swords they're like being
kicking jumping and even introduced that
Donatello saber yeah I know I'm sure
it's called something else but I call
the dontel a saber all of this is much
better in contrast to the first film
obi-wan remember when we fought in that
volcano through a pool of lava and death
surfing on tiny little machines and
doing flips and kicks everywhere yea-ah
do we got so old preach this is back
when Ray Park was in everything Sleepy
Hollow x-men ballistic usually
choreographed his own stunts and this
movie was no exception he does some
awesome work as Darth Maul and let's
face it he kicks some legitimate ass
not to mention that kick-ass Gordo
company at to affect let's give that an
11.5 on this list the more I think about
if you couldn't get into the story at
least you could get into the action
number ten
let's judge as the films went on yeah I
know this kind of shouldn't count seeing
how making up for a mistake still
technically means it's a mistake but
think about how much Lucas doesn't like
to go back on an alteration he's already
made it took forever to get the original
Star Wars non special edition DVDs out
and for awhile he didn't even want to
he just wanted people to remember the
newer effects and the newer scenes he
didn't want to change Greedo shooting
first he didn't want to change the dance
scene in Jabba's palace once he's
convinced something is better he tries
his damnedest to stay in that mindset so
it's welcoming that after one movie he
decided to cut down Jar Jar arguably a
characterized version of syphilis to a
much smaller role he'll in the third
film he doesn't even get a line this
isn't making an alteration years after a
movie has come out this is making an
alteration while you're making the movie
and considering Lucas's background for
change I think that's really saying
something for someone who is banking so
much on his humor to win over America
yeah give credit when a guy finally
realizes a mistake and tries to fix it
even if it is just one that he fixed but
like I said it's a pretty big
Norman I
Yoda kicking ass on the one hand I
really didn't want to see this as I
always saw you as that guy who had so
much power he can move a starship with
his finger I don't know I just got the
feeling a guy like that could blink and
you could probably blow up or something
but I gotta be honest seeing somebody
that small move like this is both
hilarious and kind of Awesome you just
don't see it coming and it's nice how in
the last film we do see him moving big
objects around as well as just swinging
around the sword so he's kind of using
all his abilities to his effect which of
course asks the question why does he
need that cane if he's so fit why
couldn't he just use his powers to give
his enemies a heart attack I know tons
and tons of things that don't add up but
still if it means watching Crouching
Tiger Hidden Muffet I don't give a shit
I love watching it and some great action
I mean come on it's gotta be a lot
better than this love banter they're so
beautiful
it's only because I'm sewing that number
eight
this see you wanna buy some death sticks
you don't want to sell me death sticks I
don't want to sell you death sticks you
want to go home and rethink your life I
want to go home everything in my life
there's nothing else to say I just think
it's funny for a series so devoid of
good humor this actually makes a lot of
people laugh in the audience doesn't
want to sell me death sticks I don't
want to sell you death sticks you want
to go home and rethink your life that's
it I got nothing else Maxine
number seven
Anakin and Padme SRI action to being
pregnant this might be a strange scene
to focus on but I actually think it's
done quite effectively Jedi are
forbidden to fall in love get married
and have kids
so when Anakin returns to his secret
wife this is the last news he wants to
hear all right trembling with very few
lines they managed to run the gamut of
shock fear happiness and then back to
fear again that's wonderful what are we
gonna do
that's a lot to display in only a couple
seconds
it's the perfect reaction to such
gigantic news we're not gonna worry
about anything right now this is a happy
moment
the happiest moment of my life maybe
it's because so many other scenes are
devoid of natural human reaction but I
think this shows two thinking people who
know this is both a huge joy and a big
problem it's short it's quick it's the
perfect response to such a major
discovery what are we gonna do now I
don't know Disney's having the same
problem right now number six
casting Hayden Christensen as Anakin
hear me out
I'm not gonna act like this is a good
performance it's not it's bland its
emotionless every line is completely
monotone but to those guys credit nobody
gives a good performance in this movie
everybody sounds the same are we really
gonna blame samuel l.jackson for his
bland delivery you think the guy who
does this it's totally at home talking
like this
the oppression of the Sith will never
return you have lost no this is
obviously a sign of bad direction the
same kind that can turn a good actor
like Mark Wahlberg into an unfocused
twit and the happening the same kind
that told Christian Bale his Batman
voice sounded fine don't change a thing
actors have to put a lot of trust in
their directors and an unfocused
director can easily mislead a good actor
even the acting in the first Star Wars
film people forget wasn't always the
best I recognized your foul stench when
I was brought on board
no no more kind of British so what that
said I still think the choice of Hayden
Christensen was a decent one he's acted
well in other movies and he can demand
the strong presence I know this because
any scene where he isn't told to say any
bad dialogue in a monotone voice he
looks damn intimidating anytime there's
no talking and he just has to act with
his facial expressions it really works
in my opinion one of the more powerful
scenes in the prequels is where there is
no dialogue it's when Padme and Anakin
are separated and both are contemplating
what's going to happen to themselves and
each other
that is so much more powerful than any
line written in this movie so no I don't
think it's fair to put all the blame on
this guy I think he does have a fair
amount of talent just not enough to
survive from me direction but honestly
very few actors do when he's allowed to
shoot a stare without any bed writing to
get in the way tell me you don't see the
origins of one of the galaxy's most
threatening baddies
number five
the intro to Revenge of the Sith yeah
it's kind of corny and a little
overblown but people forget just how
corny an overblown the original Star
Wars trilogy was to I mean look at this
you got the space battle you got the
sword fight you got the lasers firing
you got the big diabolical villain after
two incredibly underwhelming movies
before it this was the first time I felt
like I was actually watching a new Star
Wars film it had the energy it had the
imagination it even had some of the
comedy of the original some would argue
this makes the film even more angering
as it comes so much closer to the
original trilogy only to have the
lameness of the other films show its
face again no it's because I'm so in
love with you so love is blinded you
mm-hmm but how much rather have
something closer to the original than
nothing hitting the mark at all so for
me I think this intro was a damn fun
ride another happy landing
doing the Gregor as ob1 as much as I
talk about how bland most of these
actors are the one who seems to be
perfectly cast and even managed to make
a lot of the dialogue less painful is oh
and McGregor not only does he
surprisingly command a lot of authority
but he also has an energy that carries
over from a young youth to an aging
warrior when I look at this guy I don't
see someone badly playing a role I see
young obi-wan Kenobi Vader was seduced
by the dark side of the force
I have recalibrated the code warning all
surviving Jedi to stay away he captures
the calm and collected nature of Alec
Guinness but still has the outlook of a
young man who's learning the Chancellor
will not be able to control the
thousands of star systems without
keeping the Senate intact an elegant
women sure he's still got a lot of lame
lines to say but if someone was to ask
me what I thought this guy in his youth
would be like this would be right on the
money
I will do what I must whether teacher
student young or old the spirit of
obi-wan is definitely strong in this one
so uncivilized
number three
the Emperor you know yeah yeah okay okay
taking out some of his goofy or moments
near the end the Emperor was the only
thing in all the movies that everybody
looked forward to he had a dark menacing
robe that would become famous in the
other movies but he also played a great
diplomat a great sharm er a great
deceiver and a great manipulator my
mentor told me everything about the
force even the nature of the dark side
it didn't seem like he was just
restrained to looking evil and doing
evil things like a lot of the other Star
Wars villains or heck his role in the
original trilogy he could be cheerful he
could be funny but it was all for his
diabolical need to control you have
great wisdom
Ian McDermott returns in this role and
you can tell he's having a frigging ball
with it he runs the gamut from being
incredibly subtle and sneaky to be
full-blown over-the-top psychotic are
you going to kill me I would certainly
like to
even than scenes or he's going a little
too silly he's still so much fun to
watch
he's like the Tim Curry of the Star Wars
universe you can see that whatever part
he's doing he's just going in full force
and yes seeing an old man do this kind
of sword fighting is pretty damn
ridiculous but remember he had a few
goofy scenes in Return of the Jedi too
I'm afraid the deflector shield will be
quite operational and besides there's
still more than enough moments of him
looking creepy we pretty much saw him in
every enjoyable light a good village
should be seen in why even calculating
loud and roaring joyful and content
angry bitter every time he was on screen
he stole the show
even that is silliest the Emperor and
the prequels is by far the best
character dark side of the force is a
pathway to many abilities some consider
to be unnatural number two
the different worlds one of the
disadvantages the original Star Wars had
is that while it had a decent budget it
was never so big that you could show off
in great detail how gigantic your worlds
could be now they made up for this by
keeping the locations close intimate and
having a lot of personality with the
prequels though you can show vast
landscapes entire cities incredible
backdrops we can go from a solid still
of Cloud City to circling buildings
while flying through other ships now do
I think there's too much CG and not
enough hand build sets of course I do
just like everybody does and yeah I
think one into environments are
painfully lazy can you say saltine
cracker man but for the most part we're
allowed to really see a planet from
multiple different angles and several
different locations rather than just
finding a desert and saying oh the whole
planet looks like this keep in mind - in
1999 CG was mostly used from monsters
and devices this is one of the earlier
films that created giant fantasy worlds
that went outside your everyday
environments I even liked some of the
great locations are obviously paying
homage to other great locations a lot of
people claim the Padres setup was too
similar to Ben Hur oh yeah I forgot
because nothing in the original Star
Wars was paying homage to anything else
yes it'd be better if the people in the
world gave him more of a personality
like in the original but you still gotta
give credit to the fact that a lot of
these places look pretty damn awesome
and the number one good moment from the
Star Wars prequels is the Opera House
scene from Revenge of the Sith not only
is this scene beautifully shot not only
is it dripping with atmosphere not only
is it well acted not only is it
well-written but this is the first time
in the prequels something is given to
the Star Wars mythos to make it more of
a mythos what you may ask why its own
mythos yeah think about it a lot of the
great mythologies often have their own
mythologies within their world lore the
Rings Narnia dune hell even Harry Potter
understood this but the original Star
Wars while many would agree is still a
strong mythos mostly
to its own story we get a hint about Obi
Wan's past but it's more of quick
exposition this is more mythical one
that has its roots in legend and may or
may not have happened you ever hear the
tragedy of Darth Plagueis the wise Darth
Plagueis was a Dark Lord of the Sith so
powerful and so wise he could use the
Force to influence the midi-chlorians
create their of course hinting that the
Emperor had a big part in this story but
if he did he's lying about the
identities which means the story is
already changing from person to person
but still keeping the same spirit as
well as the same focus gave became so
powerful anything he was afraid of was
losing his part which eventually of
course he did even though technically
we're learning about the dark side and
the art of bringing the dead back to
life which would come into play it isn't
being told as exposition like most Star
Wars movies
the infer doesn't sit Annika down and
say hey let me tell you something I can
do he's explaining it through a fable a
story passed on from person to person
ironic could save others from death but
not himself this takes the whole world
and its mythos it creates to a
completely different realm that the
previous Star Wars movies never touched
upon it gave us a parable that had its
start in truth but over time morphed
into something else
it's the first time not only did these
prequels add something new but it
evolves Star Wars to a different level
even if it is just one scene even if
it's not very long
it added a story within a story and
that's one of the biggest steps to
making the world you want to feel more
real be all the more believable it's the
first time the Star Wars prequels
actually involves the story to a better
place than where the original Star Wars
films started out is it possible
to learn this power not from a Jedi so
like I said we all know the problems and
we all make fun of them mercilessly but
when something strong stands out it's
still worthy to draw attention to it and
acknowledge what was closer to the right
direction at the very least I hope one
of the most hated prequel series of all
time can still be recognized for one or
two decent clever moments maybe one or
two of them may actually bring you a
little bit of joy or maybe piss you off
more I don't know either way it's still
worth the effort to see if you can find
out a little bit of goodness in a whole
lot of jaar jaar I'm gonna stop so
credit guy remember so you don't have to
you
my friends you work hard for your salary
such devotion should not go unrewarded
you have worked hard to spend your money
however you see fit to buy food
entertainment people do not buy people
buy bad instead purchase one of the most
epic DVDs in all of existence you've
earned it by the fifth year anniversary
of that guy on the glasses come the
uncanny valley spying me your broth and
Leo Thompson Brad Jones Michael Jay and
Matt Williams but surely you deserve
more than the brilliance of these men
that is why we are offering many DVD
extras including commentaries from all
the filmmakers a nostalgia critic review
of the uncanny valley could be enchanted
magical realm of sky guard and fixes
awake a little better bloop us before
it's deleted scenes you can go over to
his house kill him fuck his wife have
some more kids it's great interviews is
a little bit more with Ansel Doug Walker
an uncle yo reading erotic slash fiction
about themselves oh Christ
this is really hot you and plenty more
where that came from
well not the slash fiction I'm sure
you'll have plenty enough Alex probably
too much so what are you waiting for
Internet enjoy the spoils of war claim
your treasure purchase the uncanny
the DVD today take your prize and my
director is telling me again to advise
you not to fight people you're sure
don't buy people